if you've been diagnosed with heart
failure it's important to control your
symptoms heart failure also called
congestive heart failure or CHF is a
lifelong condition in which your heart
continues to work but not as well as it
should your heart can't pump enough
blood and oxygen to meet the needs of
your
body excess fluid builds up the lungs
legs and other body tissues the symptoms
of heart failure include shortness of
breath chronic coughing or
wheezing swelling of the legs feet or
abdomen weight gain feeling tired all
the
time nausea or lack of
appetite heart
palpitations difficulty lying flat due
to feelings of
Suffocation and having to sit up to
breathe over time heart failure weakens
your heart and can shorten your life if
not well-managed
fortunately you can help control your
symptoms by following your doctor's
instructions adopting a heart healthy
lifestyle and staying aware of changes
in your
symptoms following the instructions of
your healthc care team is very important
in managing your symptoms and preventing
unnecessary AR trips to the
hospital this includes taking your
medications exactly as prescribed by
your doctor don't stop taking your
medications or skip doses take note of
any side effects and tell your doctor if
the cost of your medication is an issue
discuss other options with your doctor
your medications may include Angiotensin
converting enzyme
Inhibitors Angiotensin 2 receptor
blockers
or Angiotensin receptor neyin
Inhibitors beta
blockers mineralocorticoid receptor
antagonists also known as aldosterone
blockers or sodium glucose
co-transporter 2
Inhibitors these medicines are important
in managing heart
failure don't take any over-the-counter
medication or supplement without asking
your doctor if it's okay make and keep
all of your follow-up appointments for
both doctor's visits and lab tests get
vaccinated against the flu and pneumonia
as directed by your
doctor managing your heart failure also
means adopting a healthy lifestyle you
may need to make the following changes
eat a heart healthy diet including low
fat low cholesterol and high fiber foods
a heart healthy diet helps you maintain
or achieve a good blood BL pressure and
weight and helps prevent other
conditions that may further stress your
heart check food labels for the amounts
of these ingredients and
others limit your salt and sodium intake
to 2,000 mg a day which is less than a
teaspoon by doing the following don't
add salt when you cook or to food at the
table avoid processed and fast foods
Compare food labels and choose the items
that are lower in salt and
sodium limit your alcohol intake ask
your doctor if your condition allows you
to include any alcohol in your
diet monitor your fluid intake too much
fluid makes your heart work harder ask
your doctor how much fluid is the right
amount for
you don't
smoke nicotine increases heart rate and
blood
pressure at the same time it decreases
the amount of oxygen-rich blood
delivered to your body's
tissues become Physically Active regular
exercise through daily activities such
as gardening and housework can make you
feel
better other good exercise options with
your doctor's approval are walking
swimming and
bicycling as you exercise keep these
precautions in mind rest as needed stop
if you feel chest pain or more than
usual shortness of breath and don't
don't exercise when temperatures are
very hot or very cold your doctor may
also prescribe a cardiac rehabilitation
program that is a combination of
medically supervised exercise lifestyle
counseling and
education it is important to stay aware
of changes in your symptoms and know
when to get help using the traffic light
colors green yellow and red to assess
how you feel can help you take the
proper action to manage your heart
failure
symptoms green is your goal and means
that your symptoms are under control
continue to follow your doctor's
directions and keep all medical
appointments weigh yourself daily to see
if your body is retaining fluids do it
at the same time each day before eating
or drinking and wear the same type of
clothing or no clothes at all
record and take note of any changes in
your
weight symptoms in the yellow zone are
warning signs call your doctor
immediately if you gain two to three or
more pounds in one day or 5 pounds in
one
week have an increased shortness of
breath have difficulty sleeping due to
trouble
breathing feel persistent fast or
irregular heartbeats are feeling laded
or or as if you may
faint Red Zone symptoms are emergencies
that mean you need medical evaluation
right away call 911 If you experience
chest pain that lasts more than 15
minutes severe and ongoing shortness of
breath coughing up pink frothy foam or
fainting staying on top of your symptoms
and following your doctor's instructions
can help you manage heart failure and
reduce your trips to the
hospital to find out more about managing
heart failure talk to your Healthcare
practitioner